first step and you'll need your order
for this and I want to see where there
are important points and I'm going to
map them on to you can see I've got my
first derivative my second derivative
sorry my folks are out of my first three
minute and my second derivative you can
just see it there okay so with my rule I
say hey look i can see a stationary
point there especially important i can
see another stationary point there okay
so with my ruler because i'm trying to
plot these on the same accident just
very very lightly i'm going to go
vertically down from each of those
stationary point and i'm going to say
okay down to bed I'm anything going to
go to my first Trivium and I want to do
why and from my second stationary point
I also draw it down like that okay so
you can see stationary point one
stationary point too I know what exile
is they're going to correspond to
because that's what vertical lines means
same x value okay all right now secondly
I'm then going to get my screen for
gradient if you don't have if you don't
have agreement handwritten choose choose
something else okay and what I'm going
to do is with pluses and minuses I'm
going to indicate gradient on my
function okay so you can see I've got an
increasing function to the left of this
stationary point so I'm going to go all
my pluses here like so up to the right
in between the six two stationary points
I'm decrease since i've got negative
make it is so make it english news
negatives and then lastly to the right
of this stationary quite positive okay
now what does this indicate my green
signs tell me what will the sign of the
first derivative be what regions will
pass through ok there you can see it
should be positive negative positive and
these two points which are stationary
points what does that tell you that the
first derivative should be 0 right so
therefore now coming down to
first to review write these lines I drew
down they are zeros of the first we
video zeros of the first and
correspondingly I ought to be getting a
sort of wealth i'm going to go positive
negative not positive it's a parabola
through here right at just before i draw
this there's one other important feature
that I need up in my top graph and I'm
just kind of the water right ah can you
color okay I've got my great in there I
know roughly what regions I'm going to
go through for my first riveter my just
quickly um just going to show you hhhhhh
okay but what I'm missing of course is
the geometric feature that matches to
the secondary which is for the concavity
second derivative so you can see there
are parts of this that are okay down and
parts of it are concave up so I'm going
to draw arrows indicate concavity okay
so you can see here concave down these
are all concave down unambiguously right
this is still concave down here so if I
were to test that stationary point I
would have found that its second
derivative is negative that's why
analytical maximum relative winter and
still concave down here and here but
then it starts to get a bit blurry ok so
here is rare and like I said to you
before I get my piece of paper and I say
okay i'll definitely concave down still
definitely concave down still definitely
call came down oh I can't round here
it's starting to get a bit questionable
it's starting if i go to hear I've
definitely gone past the point of
inflection you see that it's definitely
starting to come back upwards okay so
let me go back a bit further guessing
it's somewhere around there ok
approximately there so I know my failure
so I've got my point of inflection that
aren't expecting okay and again I'm
going to take my rule and I'm going to
draw this one this time vertically all
the way down to the second derivative
why am i drawing it all the way down
because the function is zero because
it's a point of inflection the second
derivative should be zero okay so i've
got a zero-day on the second derivative
you can just barely see it doesn't have
to be okay now you are correct as we've
noticed before right there are other
cases where number one the second degree
of being zero doesn't Gary guarantee
upon reflection and a point of
inflection doesn't guarantee that the
second derivative is 0 however we know
what the special cases are right one of
the special cases for example I've got a
point infection how do I know it there's
actually yeah and you want to suggest oh
just grow why was extra-powerful okay so
X power 4 is a case now do I have it is
X to power 4 here clearly not so great I
don't worry about it secondly is the
case where I have a point of inflection
but the secondary vis look is not zero
is because I can have a point of
inflection when I don't have a second
derivative at all okay there are two
ways I can have very second derivative
two ways can you wanna remember them
this is it harder it's a like the degree
of the
review that you're trying to
differentiate is to move okay shut away
to that X ok now what you're thinking of
is interesting um I can still have
remember the question of personnel let
me try and clarify it is some graphs
they have second derivative in some
points and they have second derivative
they don't have a secondary another
point right there are only two ways you
can have do a second derivative okay
yeah yeah actually started taking back
three okay number one if the function
itself doesn't exist it's okay if up
here I have a hole well then I will have
holes all the way down right so there's
the first thing a discontinuity in the
original function okay give me another
one to there are two more are not
differentiable okay if it's not
differentiable so something like say the
absolute value of x at the absolute
value of x it exists there it is
continuous but when you differentiate
you're in trouble okay there's one more
that's what I'm looking for I'm looking
for this one like what would give me a
discontinuity in the second derivative I
gave you a classic example me right okay
so if the first derivative doesn't exist
the second building can t go what would
it mean if the first dream it doesn't
exist what's the class nevermind ready
if it's if it's vertical if it's a
straight line you still have a dream
it's just it's a constant thanks so let
me just summarize that because we just
said something it was my main point but
um no second derivative there are three
things that can make that happen number
one when you have no function okay so if
the function itself doesn't exist you
know secondly if you've got something
which is not differentiable like if it's
a like a a piece malfunction or
something like that so not
differentiable or if you have a cusp
those kinds of things it was not
differentiable of course you're not
going to get a second derivative but the
last one is if I'm if it's very cool and
we looked at the cube root of x do you
remember that now you have a look at
this one two three are any of those the
case on this function
and the answer is no it's continuous
it's differentiable it's smooth that was
my arm my informal sitting in four
different abilities and instead Lee
dong-wook vertical guess I'm all good so
therefore I know it's going to pass 20
now the reason why I point that out
before I draw my first derivative use if
the second derivative is zero Yankee
yard what does that mean about the first
derivative yeah okay there's going to be
a stationary point for the first
derivative it's going to be like some
flat like that okay now I'm ready to
control this thing okay like you said
like told me there's going to be a
parabola through these three regions so
let's just draw luckily okay like so now
even though I don't know for sure I have
every reason to guess that this is a
cubic this is a quadratic which makes
this last one a straight line it's
linnea right now just quickly thinking
about going back to the concavity up
here right I said concave down all the
way here but I didn't finish it over on
the right-hand side that point
inflection it's all concave up function
so what does that mean about the regions
that my second derivative passes through
well if it's concave down it should have
a negative second derivative right and
if it's concave up it should have a
positive second derivative so now I know
where my second deriv is going to go
it's going to look something like this
and of course the actual slant of this I
have no idea but it doesn't really
matter I have the general shape and
that's all you can be expected to know
when you don't have any numbers all you
have is well yeah the general shape ok
does that make sense